in this lesson we're going to talk about
an important concept to understand for
the new s80 and that's similar triangles
so what are similar triangles and how do
we work with them we're gonna go through
a couple examples so let's get right
into this lesson so first of all what
similar triangles are there are
triangles that have the same shape but
not necessarily the same size so the
corresponding angles are going to be
congruent meaning equal but the
corresponding sides are going to be
proportional so for example they tell us
that these two triangles are similar
what you can see is like 3 is 2 6 s 2 is
to 4 you can see that what's happening
here is we're multiplying by 2 this
triangle is the site links are two times
as long as in this triangle so if we set
up a proportion we can see 3 is 26 as
for is 2x and then what we can do is we
can cross multiply like this so you can
see 3x equals 24 divided by 3 and x
equals 8 or you can just use that scale
factor where we're saying okay I'm
doubling so three times two is six four
times two is eight but again the idea is
that if the triangles are similar the
corresponding sides are proportional now
there's three different ways to prove
triangles similar you probably member
this from your geometry class you can
either show that two angles in one
triangle are congruent to two angles in
another triangle and this is probably
the most common way that you'll see it
on the s80 and that's it you know this
angle this thing was the same the thing
well this thing all are the same
therefore we know that these two
triangles are similar and we can make a
proportion with the corresponding sides
these other two ways side side side
that's just saying that you know if all
three sides in one triangle are in the
same ratio as all three sides in the
other triangle the triangles are similar
and then here with side angle side
they're showing you like this angle here
in between the two sides is the same but
the ratio of the two sides that make up
that angle they're in the same ratio but
the main thing is this angle angle
similarity that we talked about up here
so let's get into some examples go ahead
and pause the video so you can do these
on your own will goal term together
definitely important concept understand
for the f80
so the first one it says if you're six
feet tall and it cast a shadow that's
two feet long and a nearby tree casts a
20-foot shadow how tall is the tree so
go ahead and pause the video do that
question and we'll go through it
together so basically when you have a
problem like this and there's not a
diagram I would draw a diagram so here's
you know here's the person right this is
a you right you're six feet tall and
you're casting a shadow like this two
feet long okay and then over here here's
a tree okay see if I can draw a tree
here for you like that right and what's
happening is this one's casting a shadow
and they tell us that the shadow is a 20
feet long okay now what you're going to
notice here is that we're assuming that
you're standing you know vertical to the
ground so this is going to be a right
angle just like the tree we're assuming
is vertically ground that's at a right
angle and then the sun's over up here is
casting you know it's raised down like
this so this angle of elevation right
here and this angle of elevation right
here they're the same so what we have is
we have two angles in one triangle
congruence and two angles the other
triangle therefore we know that the
triangles are similar we can make a
proportion so all we're going to do is
we're just going to say the height of
you compared to the height of the tree
so 6 is 2 H as your shadow is to the
tree shadow so you want to keep it
consistent like that where you're doing
height to height shadow to shadow you
can also do it like the ratio of your
height to your shadows the same ratio as
the trees height to the tree shadow but
I just like to keep it consistent where
I'm saying your height to the trees
height your shadow to the tree shadow
keep it consistent like that then you
can just cross multiply like this across
the diagonals so each times two gives
you 2 h 6 x 20 gives you 120 divided
everything by 2 and you can see that the
height of the tree is going to be 60
feet okay let's get into example number
two so here we're just giving us a
diagram and they're saying find X okay
that's this length of the side right
here so go ahead and pause the video see
if you can find the length of X and
we'll go through it together so
basically what you want to notice in
this set up here or this diagram is that
see these double arrows right here that
represents these two lines are parallel
okay so if you extend these lines these
are parallel lines
and they're cut by this transversal
which means that these angles are going
to be congruent their alternate interior
angles okay you remember that from your
geometry class ones on the left side of
the transversal ones on the right and
they're in between these parallel lines
they're going to be congruent same thing
over here with this transversal this
angle here and this angle here are going
to be congruent by alternate interior
angles and you probably also remember
the vertical angles when you have two
lines across the angles that are across
from each other those are going to be
congruent right so basically what we
have is we have at least two angles in
one triangles congruent to two angles on
the other triangle we know that they're
similar we can make a proportion with
the corresponding side but here's where
students go a little bit wrong and
that's that you have to take this bottom
triangle and rotate it 180 degrees
because you want this thing all the
match up with this angle this thing will
do match up with this angle so we're
turning it right so what happens is this
side here too is not matching up with 12
it's actually matching up with X so
we're going to make the ratio to is 2x
as four matches up with 12 okay so you
see that that's important otherwise you
could compare the wrong side you're
going to get the wrong answer so we're
going to cross multiply now and we've
got four times x equals 2 times 12 which
is 24 divided by four and you can see
that x equals 6 and you got it so again
review this lesson if you need to just
to understand how similar triangles work
essentially what it is is making a
proportion in solving that proportion
I'll see you in the next lesson